hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the Christmas edition of
the try not to smile challenge I have
here before me a number of videos that
are supposedly heartwarming loving so
sweet and tender
but I won't smile and neither will you
because if any of us smile we will be
don't know so try your best not to smile
at these heartwarming seasonal videos
who knows what's gonna happen I mean
obviously in front of me right now I
have a funny feeling and what's gonna
happen but doesn't mean I'm out of smile
all right everybody get ready
think of terrible thoughts unhappiness
let the darkness flow out of your soul
here we go
you are not cute
you're not cute you are not cute you're
not cute
you're not cute no nothing nothing at
all cuz it wasn't entertaining in any
way whatsoever oh you cute but now
hmm no it's not cute no that poor cat is
trapped by its boots not a smile not a
damn smile not a damn smile what cruel
owners to put this cat through this
torment what cruel cruel owners not
smiling I'm gonna have to do that thing
where you laugh without actually smiling
you know anyway oh god no no it's a Korg
Oh No
good effort good for kid good effort
good effort good effort
[Music]
nope you know is not adorable this
dangerous
all those people standing too close to
the yellow line it's just bad news who
knows what could happen somebody could
fall bad I'm disappearing for them
little kid not wholesome stupid yeah
[Music]
[Music]
some smart cats no no no no no the
corners of my mouth are tried to betray
me oh it's gonna be harder than I fly if
you smiled yet did you smile at that be
honest be honest tell everyone if you
smiled I knew was covering I knew it I
don't think I smiled
oh wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow
wow wow wow wow wow I'm amazed by that
I'm I'm amazed but not enough to smile
not enough to smile I'm Amit that's
amazing that's amazing but not enough to
smile this is this unbelievable look
this is incredible look at the detail on
this stuff look at the detail tiny
gingerbread house the fire Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
no no no no don't try to scoop it back
oh yeah I think I'm crying I think I'm
crying I think I'm crying he's hurt so
bad to try not to smile
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you guys not smile
kind of soulless demons re anyway so
that was the try not to smile Christmas
edition thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below if you smiled
you're the same boat as I we have to
commit herself the school lifetime of
non happiness and if you didn't smile
wow you are a robot so congratulations
take that with pride and thank you again
everybody for watching if you enjoyed
this check out my other videos I got
more trying out to smiles I got more try
not to laughs a whole bunch of other
videos so organized and playlist I'll
put a bunch of stuff in the description
below check it out if you'd like to see
it check the annotations wherever they
are thanks again and as always I will
see you in the next video bye